time to adapt to a new normal as the
country confronts the realities of
coronavirus and says there is a long
road ahead joining us now is the former
director of the Centers for Disease
Control dr. Tom Frieden dr. freedom
welcome back to Fox News Sunday and on a
personal level good to see you we
interacted a lot when I was in Atlanta
both of us were there good to see you
again good to see you
so let me ask you first of all where do
you think we are heading with this with
the number of infections rising we're on
the infection curve are we are we
expecting tens of thousands of cases in
the next few days and weeks or are we
expecting hundreds of thousands of cases
well first off we're in different places
in different parts of the US and
different parts of the world and that's
why it's so important that state and
local health departments and governments
have a key role here in tracking what's
happening locally not only with the
virus but with the healthcare system and
advising people on what to do here in
New York City where I am today we are
really telling everyone stay home and in
New York City where the hospitals are
getting overwhelmed we're saying if you
have mild illness don't get tested stay
home because it's not gonna change
anything even if you're positive we're
gonna say stay home and if you go out
there to get tested you may use up
testing supplies to use a protective
equipment use up time and effort of the
healthcare workers and if you're not
infected you might get infected if you
are infected you might infect someone
else so mild illness New York City today
stay home where we're going first off
really important to get one key concept
takes on average 5 or 6 days from the
time someone gets infected to look when
they get sick and about another week
before they get very sick so the severe
cases we're seeing today are people who
were infected 10 to 14 days ago that
means that for the next 10 to 14 days
we're likely to continue to see a big
increase in cases in places like New
York City that's why we're so worried
about health care becoming overwhelmed
and keeping our health care workers as
safe as possible dr. Mike Ryan of the
World Health Organization says that
lockdowns are are not enough reading the
quote from him he says what we really
need to focus on is finding those who
are sick those who have the virus and
isolate them find their contacts and
isolate them but I was talking to
somebody at the CDC just on Friday who
told me that
CDC's not really doing a whole lot of
contact tracing anymore because now the
disease is so widespread it depends on
where you are in a place night like New
York City where we have tens of
thousands of infections maybe hundreds
of thousands already finding the sources
of cases and the contacts isn't going to
work what you want to do is drive down
new infections by these social
distancing stay home wash your hands
don't shake hands stay at least six feet
away from almost everyone and then over
the next two to three weeks we might
expect to see after that starts with a
lag of a couple weeks for the previously
infected people a drive down of cases
and that's when you restart really
aggressive testing contact tracing
isolation ultimately what you want to do
is tamp down cases and anywhere in the
country anywhere in the world where
cases are just coming in you want to try
to find the new cases
anyone who's sick isolate identify the
contact so that they can be quarantined
and isolated if they become sick and we
know that you have personal experience
with that as well in the Ebola crisis of
a number of years ago as well isolating
people treating them in terms of a
vaccine we know that we're still at
least probably a year away but there is
some promising therapies that seem to be
on the horizon one of them as an old
friend that was used as an anti malarial
agent was given to every u.s. GI pretty
much who went to Vietnam during the
Vietnam War chloroquine or
hydroxychloroquine some evidence that in
combination with a very common
antibiotic as if through Meissen it can
shorten the course of disease but there
seems to be some debate over whether or
not that should be deployed President
Trump very bullish on a dr. Anthony
Fauci of the National Institutes of
Allergy and Infectious Disease a little
more circumspect let's listen to both of
them talking about it here we're trying
to strike a balance between making
something with a potential of an ant of
an effect to the American people
available at the same time that we do it
under the auspices of a protocol that
would give us information to determine
if it's truly safe and truly effective
I'm probably more of a fan of that
and maybe than anybody gets early but
we've you know I've seen things that are
impressive and we'll see we're going to
know soon we're gonna know soon
including safety so the president has
said dr. Frieden what the hell do you
have to lose we've got this treatment
that we've had this drug that's out
there we've known it for almost 70 years
now do you think it should be trotted it
be deployed we all hope there'll be good
treatment for people with severe
infection with this virus because that
would make a big difference
recently just last week two of the best
antiviral drugs were tried in
combination and they didn't show any
impact things seemed promising but until
you studied them until you really figure
out does it work we don't know so
absolutely I think we should urgently
figure out whether chloroquine
hydroxychloroquine azithromycin have an
impact on the outcomes of disease we
have three goals here reduce the number
of infections improve the outcomes in
people who have infection and reduce the
societal and economic harms of this
pandemic you say that there's two big
stories coming in the next week what do
you see coming down the tracks
sadly in places like New York City and
elsewhere I'm afraid we will see an
increasing number of health care workers
infected some of whom may get severely
ill and the potential that we will
overwhelm some of our intensive care
capacity that's what I'm most concerned
about for the coming week the models
that we've seen and the trends that
we're seeing are extremely concerning
remember I said it's about 7 10 14 days
from the time of infection to severe
illness that means the severe illness
we're seeing now was a result of
infections that happened almost two
weeks ago and in those last two weeks
there's been an escalating number of
cases so the possibility of having
tremendous stress on our healthcare
system our intensive care units our
nurses our doctors transporters everyone
who works in the health care system and
with that more risk of infections in
health care more risks of patients dying
that's very concerning and that's why in
New York City and elsewhere people are
scrambling to try to scale up the
capacity to care for patients safely but
that's not easy to do this is very
involved intensive
when you were the director of the CDC
you were always on the front lines we
saw you there in Africa and all of your
protective equipment as you were looking
at what was going on with the Ebola
crisis firsthand are you concerned that
the Centers for Disease Control has been
sidelined somewhat in the in the public
aspect of this we haven't seen dr.
Redfield for days now I would feel a lot
safer if it were clear that the CDC is
both at the table where the decisions
are being made and at the podium where
they're being explained the CDC is the
nation's leading health protection
agency one of the Centers within the CDC
is the National Center for immunization
respiratory disease they have more than
700 medical professionals who are
experts in the understanding and control
of infectious diseases and in order to
do more and protect people more we need
their full involvement fighting this
without CDC central to the response has
never been done with an infectious
disease threat in the US before and it's
like fighting with one hand tied behind
your back the president is getting high
marks from people like Governor Cuomo of
New York governor Newsom of California
for working with the states on trying to
combat this this virus you've been
watching there from your perch in New
York City what this White House has been
doing how would you grade the
president's response because he has been
criticized by people as well this is not
a time for grading this is a time for
all of us to work together for every
part of the federal government for
individuals for people to pull together
against a common enemy
a dangerous microbe there's something
everyone can do stay home
wash your hands don't go out if you're
sick there's something that our health
care system needs to do prepare for a
safer surge to care for patients and
also keep people who need their their
medications for hypertension or diabetes
or other illnesses keep them safe and on
medications through telemedicine
refilled prescriptions all of us can
play a role and one thing we have to do
more is to understand this virus how
it's spreading and how to control it
better the better we understand it the
better we can protect people
let me quickly if I could dr. Frieden
come back to where we started because
you didn't give me a number at the
beginning did you believe we'll see tens
of thousands of cases or hundreds of
thousands of cases here in the United
I think we already have many times more
cases than have been detected in places
like New York City we already have tens
or hundreds of thousands of infections
there's no doubt from the information
that we're seeing the challenge is what
can we do today that's gonna slow down
this really exponential phase of the
increase that's accelerating pandemic
and that's possible by people staying
home avoiding social contact we're all
in this together and what each one of us
does can protect all of us one one real
quick question if I could any idea how
long this is going to last very hard to
predict what's going to happen this is
unprecedented it's never happened before
but we do have by working together
within us the ability to change the
trajectory of this pandemic what will
happen in the coming months only the
coming months will tell but what we do
is within our power dr. Frieden always
good to see it thanks for taking the
time appreciate it
nice to speak with you again John